استخبارات حكومية جيدة لسوق الأوراق المالية ،
حتى قدرتنا على
العمل من المنزل أثناء الوباء ،
فجميعهم لديهم شيء واحد
في الذكاء الاصطناعي المشترك ،
ليس فقط
هنا لتبقى بعض القلق أو بصراحة تامة
أنها تتولى زمام الأمور ،
لذا تحاول الإمارات العربية المتحدة أن
تقود الطريق  وجود
وزارته الخاصة
للذكاء الاصطناعي وعمر العلامة هو المعالج التكنولوجي الذي يضع ذكاءه السيبراني للعمل من أجل بلده في سن 30 عامًا ، فهو لا يتحمل الكثير من المسؤولية المهنية فحسب ، بل يقود أيضًا حياة مزدوجة تناسبها جون ديبتيرا
ذهب
في الرحلة ، كانت الساعة الرابعة والنصف صباحًا
وبدأ عمر علاء لاما في
روتينه اليومي ،
إنها حياة مزدوجة غير عادية حيث يقود
ساعة واحدة إلى معسكر تدريب عسكري للحرس الرئاسي
لم أكن أتوقع أنني سأعيش حياة مزدوجة
صحيح
أنني في الخدمة العسكرية أو
مجند في الخدمة الوطنية في
الصباح وأنهم يخدمون في المساء
بينما تشرق الشمس عبر
ضباب صحراوي كثيف ، وزير Artifi الإماراتي البالغ من العمر 30 عامًا
الذكاء الأساسي موجود في تشكيلة الفريق مع بقية الفصيلة التي يتم أخذهم عبر خطواتهم ، حيث تبدأ مسيرة ثلاثة كيلومترات في كامل العتاد يومًا صارمًا من التدريب يليه دورة تدريبية وعقبات لمدة 10 دقائق للإفطار لتزويدك بالطاقة و لقد خرجت إلى ميدان الرماية تتزامن زيارتنا مع معلم بارز من نوع ما للوزير وهو عام واحد من الخدمة الوطنية معقدة بالطبع بسبب جائحة covet 19 في جولته الأولى التي أصاب فيها أولاما هدفه ولكنه كان هدفه منخفضًا لذلك تم توجيهه إلى قم بإجراء تعديلات ، فهذه هي الجولة الأولى ، نعم ، إنها الجولة الثانية ، إنه تغيير كبير ، حيث يقطع القليل من المعايرة شوطًا طويلاً ، لذا فقط بالنسبة لبعض التعديلات ، فإن أول شيء عليك القيام به عندما تأتي من خلال البوابات هو إيقاف غرورك عند الباب على اليمين وكأنك تولد من جديد ، لا يهم كم لديك في الحساب المصرفي خارج المخيم ، لا يهم من هو والدك ، ولا يهم ما هي رتبتك  ما
يهم هو مدى جودة الطالب العسكري
وكيف يمكنك فهم ما يتم
تقديمه لك وتطبيقه.
بدأت دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة التي بلغت الخمسين من العمر العام المقبل
خدمتها الوطنية الإلزامية
في عام 2014
للرجال الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 18 و 30 عامًا.
لمساعدة الدولة على
صد التهديدات الإقليمية ،
يتم تقييم كل طالب يوميًا عبر
اثنتي عشرة فئة
من كيفية تنظيف بندقيته إلى
العمل الجماعي ، يمكنهم تعلم
العديد من الأشياء مثل
مهارات إدارة الانضباط في القيادة والإدارة المالية
على نطاقات صغيرة ويمكن أن تساعدهم هذه الأشياء
عندما  العودة إلى حياتهم المدنية ،
يحتاج أولاما إلى إجراء هذا
الانتقال المدني خمسة أيام في الأسبوع
مرة أخرى في مكتبه في مؤسسة دبي للمستقبل ،
حيث يصل وهو يرتدي حارسه العسكري
ويعود للظهور مرتديًا الكندورة العربية التقليدية
التي يقودها مع اجتماع فريق العمل
لوضع اللمسات الأخيرة  لمنتدى تقني في
اليوم التالي
وقمة الحكومة العالمية في وقت لاحق
من العام ،
انضممت إليه في جلسة مع
مبرمجي الكمبيوتر المجندين  من بين صفوف
الخدمة الوطنية
، لديهم تفويض لتطوير
منصة برمجيات
تجارية للشحن بعد ذلك بوقت قصير ،
يرحب أولاما بوفد إسرائيلي في
دبي لاستكشاف التعاون في مجال التكنولوجيا الفائقة.
الكثير من الخبرة
بين المعرفة بين
خدمة الضرر والاقتصاد بعد
ذلك لأنه معمل صغير
[موسيقى] ،
إنه برنامج ناشئ هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
لكن أوباما يقول بعد مرور عام على
واجباته العسكرية
أنه أقرب كثيرًا إلى
ناخبيه  تجعلك تشعر بأنك
نعم ، فأنا بحاجة إلى خدمتهم بشكل أفضل ، وأحتاج
إلى القيام بعمل أفضل
وأحتاج أيضًا إلى إعادة تنظيم
أولوياتي بناءً على احتياجاتهم
كجيل والآخرين بالإضافة
إلى أسس مستهلكة
لعضو مجلس الوزراء الشاب هذا  أنه يأمل أن
يكون قدوة
للآخرين لاتباع جون ديتريوس سي إن إن
دبي